abdullah wohnte tatsächlich genau im
haus hinter mir gegenüber in einem
gefängnis und
wir sind heute hier hingefahren und
haben mit ihnen gesprochen die ihr leben
und auch mit einem mitschüler der sagte
mir
das abdullah ein respektierter junger
mann gewesen sei sei ein boxer gewesen
freundlich hätte sich so was nie
vorstellen können und ein nachbar sagte
mir dass
er glaubte dass abdullah sich im
internet radikalisiert hat bei instagram
bei twitter hatte es ja ein regelrechtes
tribunal gegen den lehrer gegeben der
die mohammed-karikatur gezeigt hatte und
wie lebten die tschetschenische
gemeinschaft eu hier leben circa 45
familien sagte mir der nachbar und sie
sind allesamt aus
russland hierher geflohen denn sie haben
ja den tschetschenien krieg miterlebt
bei dem russland großen platt gemacht
hatte und ein älterer hygiene sagte mir
dass er nicht verstehen könne wie der
junge der 18 ist und hier zwölf jahre in
frieden lebte sich so hat radikalisieren
können denn er hatte ja gar nicht mehr
den schrecklichen bürgerkrieg
mitbekommen es konnte er sich nicht
erklären und
die menschen hier sagten mir sie sind
schockiert davon tatsache ist aber auch
so dass immer noch fünf
familienmitglieder des jung im gewahrsam
sind da man prüfen will ob sie eine
verbindung zum anschlag haben
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren